cet homme a décidé de prendre tous les
risques tous les samedis soirs il va
relever un formidable d'effet vous tenez
en haleine pendant une heure pour vous
empêcher de zapper et conserver son
argumente
tous les moyens sont bons même la
qualité
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur le plateau
d'ardimat comme vous le savez j'ai pris
un pari fou auprès de la direction de la
Chaîne celui de vous tenir en haleine
tous les samedis soirs pendant une heure
si vous zappez si je ne fais pas assez
d'ardimat je suis viré
pour éviter ça à ma femme et à mes
enfants j'aime ma disposition tout ce
qui a été tourné depuis l'invention de
la caméra je me suis également adjoint
les services d'un expert St télévision
le professeur Rollin que certains
d'entre vous connaissent déjà professeur
j'ai par ailleurs demandé à deux
téléspectateurs moyens d'être présent
sur le plateau de agir quand il le
désirent il rende bonsoir Jean-Pierre
bonsoir
Jean-Pierre et moi de les autres
c'est-à-dire vous chez vous vous pouvez
également réagir en appelant le 36 65 71
23 voilà je sais que ce dispositif me
permettra de faire exploser leurs images
et grâce à vous nous allons triomphé
dans votre élan mais enfin vous
n'arrivera rien comme ça enfin
franchement qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
cinéma là qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
en phrase ridicule qu'est-ce que c'est
que ce décor homme pompier vous croyez
que vous allez vous rendre sympathique
avec ce déballage mussolinien je
présente bah oui mais parce qu'il est là
le problème Thierry les gens ne vous
trouvent pas sympathique tous les
sondages j'en ai encore un fou les yeux
toutes les enquêtes le montrent vous
avez une mauvaise image dans le public
les gens le disent quand on les
interroge ils disent si excusez-moi les
sondages le montrent les les gens disent
il y a une chose qu'on n'aime pas dans
les émissions d'Ardisson c'est Ardisson
voilà j'y peux rien c'est comme ça
prouvez-le ah mais justement vous tombez
bien Thierry parce que la chaîne a fait
préparer un micro-trottoir pour vous le
démontrer si vous voulez jeter un œil
prenez votre petit téléviseur regardez
mon regard est-ce que tu connais Thierry
Ardisson oui tu aimes bien non
provocateur et il m'énerve quand gros tu
peux lui dire là qu'il est antipathique
oui je peux ouais vas-y ben je vais pas
me gêner Thierry tu es antipathique
ouais salut chips pourquoi tu trouves
Ardisson antipathique c'est vrai que
j'aime pas du tout moi seulement il fait
un peu trop de conneries je trouve et il
critique un peu trop il veut il veut
jouer au grand tout ça devant devant
tous les gens tout ça avant tout le
monde il veut se la donner quoi c'est un
peu le beau ouais voilà il fait un peu
le beau exactement tu as l'impression
qu'il est franc j'ai l'impression qu'il
est franc mais qu'il en fait un peu trop
quel niveau bah il est sûr de lui
il se veut prendre mais bon je sais pas
s'il est franchement il est complètement
faux je crois qu'il est un peu focus
surtout dans sa façon de rire sans
sourire est pas franc voilà je déteste
en sourire c'est surtout ça c'est quoi
son sourire
crispé
ça vous déplaît oui complètement il
sourit un peu trop vêtements mettons
rien trop bêtement il rit on sent qu'il
est parfois gêné quoi très joli sourire
tout est bien fait quoi je veux dire
il a un physique tu trouves qu'il est
trop payé hier dis ça je sais pas
combien il est payé plein de zéro plein
de zéro bah tant mieux pour lui qu'il en
profite sur la tête pas durer qu'est-ce
que je peux faire pour me rendre
sympathique moi écoutez Thierry prenons
les problèmes dans l'ordre regardons le
premier reproche les gens disent Thierry
Ardisson est lointain par le faux il
sourit faux il n'est pas assez proche
des gens deuxième reproche on dit
Ardisson n'est pas généreux on dit il
roule pour qu'est-ce qu'ils en savent
les gens et gens le disent Thierry moi
je regarde les enquêtes je vous demande
pas de de commencer à discuter chaque
point les gens disent ils ne s'intéresse
qu'à lui-même il se fichent du reste
alors à votre place je ferai un geste là
encore pour montrer que vous avez un
cœur quoi donc
par exemple moi je fais un don
Thierry vous prenez les français pour
des imbéciles ici sur un plateau de
télévision alors on dit je fais un don
et puis dans 25 minutes on ira tout
dépenser en boîte de nuit alors si vous
voulez faire un don regardez les gens et
faites un don maintenant en direct
devant tout le monde bon ben comme un
porte comme un porte mon carnet de
chèques s'il vous plaît il est dans la
dans la poche de mon imperméable
vous allez donner à qui
faut que je vous le dise à qui je donne
sinon si c'est pour me donner à moi
Thierry ça s'appelle pas un don
écoutez je vais donner à la paroisse de
mon
de mon quartier voilà c'est un
philippe-du-roule catholique je sais pas
si c'est ce que vous avez trouvé de
mieux pour vous rendre sympathique
faites discutez pas parce que sinon on
va y passer deux heures il donnera rien
du tout vous allez donner combien 10000
ouais
par rapport à ce que vous gagnez
j'estime que 15000 aura été plus juste
enfin sonnerie
ok ben écoutez Thierry je crois qu'on a
déjà un petit peu remonter la pente en
tout cas j'espère
voilà je vous laisse poursuivre
l'émission je crois qu'on est ça va
mieux là mon image à mon sens ça
s'améliore attendez tout le travail ne
sera pas en un jour parce qu'on vient de
loin loin loin loin loin
je dois vous remercie
je suis là pour vous donner des conseils
encore un mot avant de commencer cette
émission j'aime beaucoup les chiens il y
en a un dans l'équipe d'hardimat que
tout le monde adore vous le voyez en ce
moment sur votre écran il s'appelle Zapp
je l'aime beaucoup moi aussi je dois
vous dire que si mardi Matt descend en
dessous de 15%
nous serons obligés de tuer ce chien
j'aime pas le chantage
c'est comme ça
comme vous le savez TF1 avait coutume de
diffuser le samedi soir l'excellente
émission de Nicolas Hulot
ushuaya mais désormais TF1 diffuse le
samedi soir à cette heure-là un téléfilm
américain ce soir visage de tueurs je
vous le dis monsieur mujote je te le dis
Étienne c'est pas sympa ça
si le jeu si le jeu c'est de diffuser
des séries américaines tout le monde
peut le faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans la série Les Envahisseurs
[Musique]
avec
le rôle de David Vincent
Diane Baker
oui je sais président oui oui je sais
c'est le service public oui le service
public je sais oui
pas de série américaine à part 10h Stone
et restaure hop OK et des séries
françaises avec Kouchner
oui Thierry je comprends la réaction de
la chaîne c'est normal il y a un
problème de déontologie
par contre il y a peut-être une autre
solution vous savez plutôt que d'essayer
d'attirer la clientèle chez nous sur
cette chaîne on peut peut-être tout
simplement la décourager d'aller sur
l'autre chaîne et en faisant quoi ben
peut-être on leur racontant la fin de la
série en question à pas mal vous la
connaissez
bien sûr je vais vous raconter la fin du
téléfilm visage de tueur qui passe en ce
moment sur TF1 celui que l'on prend pour
l'assassin le jeune policier mais en
fait qu'un pigeon et le commanditaire de
l'assassinat n'est autre que le chef de
la police à la fin de visage de tueur en
ce moment sur TF1 le gentil professeur
d'escalade tue le chef de la police
après une courte poursuite sur la façade
du building voilà donc vous pouvez
rester sur France 2 puisque vous
connaissez la fin du téléfilm de TF1
pour faire de l'audimat tout est
possible interview de trucs et reality
show film de cul mais pour faire de
l'art d'images il faut savoir traiter
sobrement de l'actualité quitte à faire
réfléchir les gens Sarajevo quels sont
aujourd'hui les risques réels d'une
guerre mondiale
Sarajevo dimanche 28 juin 1914 tout
commence
l'archiduc François-Ferdinand héritier
du trône d'Autriche-Hongrie et son
épouse tombe sous les balles du jeune
étudiant bosniaque gavilo
[Musique]
ce drame frappe douloureusement le vieil
empereur François-Joseph dont les
espoirs s'écroulent
l'empereur d'Allemagne Guillaume II
donne son appui total à François-Joseph
deux jours après la déclaration de
guerre de l'Autriche à la Serbie la
Russie mobilise le 30 juillet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le premier roux c'est au tour de la
France de décréter la mobilisation
générale en même temps que l'Allemagne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le 3 août c'est la guerre et les
Allemands pénètrent en Belgique
le 4 août l'Angleterre en elle aussi
dans le conflit tout est consommé et 5
semaines après Sarajevo la Première
Guerre mondiale de l'histoire est
déclenchée
nul ne s'est alors qu'elle durera 4 ans
et fera 7 millions de morts
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
vous venez d'insister au prémices de la
Première Guerre mondiale passons
maintenant à ceux de la deuxième
ouais ouais bien joué boss j'ai rarement
vu un garçon faire un match comme lui ce
soir bonne balle de Platini pour Batista
à côté mais c'est pas vrai
mais
que se passe-t-il
mais regardez regardez Schumacher c'est
carrément de l'agression
oh là là
du football comme un arbre
logiquement l'arbitre de touche devait
le signaler ce geste de Schumacher est
tout à fait inadmissible
[Applaudissements]
très lourde responsabilité
regardez encore l'action une fois au
ralenti Schumacher arrive et c'est
délibérément qu'il force dans Battiston
raconter le ballon
visiblement il se passe quelque chose
platiné à les reins qui est Baptiste
toujours au sol et voici Michel Hidalgo
qui vient aux nouvelles Michelin qui est
son visage des mauvais jours la civière
qui arrive et ça doit être très grave
l'amitié franco-allemande en prend un
coup
[Musique]
mais oui il faut courir messieurs Couret
ma question souffle
sur cette pelouse de douleur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est absolument anti sportif et
scandale regardez
[Applaudissements]
Michel Hidalgo toujours inquiet
l'arbitre va siffler probablement un
penalty on le ferait à moins
Michel colère
Platini qui tient la main de son copain
Baptiste ton qui souffre
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui 76% des Français
sont partisans d'une intervention en
Bosnie mais on ne sait pas combien sont
d'accord à condition que ce soit le fils
du voisin qui parle on ne sait pas
encore combien seront d'accord quand la
télé montrera les mamans accompagnant
leurs enfants sur le port de Toulon
quand la télé montrera le retour des
premiers cercueils attention les départs
à la guerre c'est toujours plus beau au
cinéma
[Musique]
mon amour je
t'attendrai toute ma vie je ne penserai
qu'à toi
ne part pas je t'en supplie ouais c'est
moi
mon amour
encore le je m'éloigne de toi ne me
regarde
pas
je ne peux pas je ne peux pas
[Musique]
mon amour je
t'aime mon amour
je t'aime
[Musique]
au cinéma mais la guerre à la télé c'est
comment bien avancé du Golfe pendant
celle des Malouines Jean-Luc Godard se
demandait déjà est-ce de l'info est-ce
de l'intox
je passais dans la rue là j'ai entendu
ça y est ça repart patron je suis prêt
non j'ai bien entendu
c'est fini Philippe
j'ai un truc je t'appelle ah ouais te
jeune pas la cortisone allez à bientôt
Philippe au revoir salut
pauvre Corti Jean-Luc Godard bon
réflexion sur cet événement
mais vous avez je sais pas si vous avez
besoin de moi pour pour dialoguer c'est
difficile avec vous à la télé vous
parlez beaucoup vous montrer quelques
images assez pauvres qui peuvent prendre
en dire grand chose j'ai regardé par
exemple hier une émission enfin au
journal il y avait un petit documentaire
que vous avez fait vous vous
interviewiez des Anglais et je pense
même pas qu'on peut le revoir ici ça
doit être avec tout votre matériel vous
devez même pas pouvoir revoir une image
que vous avez montré hier bien sûr que
si on peut et ben si moi forcement
celle-là vous nous l'avez vous de l'avez
demandé un peu tard là en direct
moi je travaille avec des images et ce
qui m'intéresse si j'étais à la
télévision ça serait de me servir des
images pour voir quelque chose que sinon
on dit comme pays 12 ou pôle 7 je sais
pas il faut pas tuer avec des mots mais
c'est un mot en plus et on ne se sert
pas des trucs et là pendant hier c'est
juste que je voulais vous dire ça m'a
fait réfléchir il y avait des vieux et
des jeunes les vieux étaient pour en
découdre et tu es les jeunes disaient ça
me rend malade il y avait un jeune
anglais qui parlait un peu coquenet et
qui disait écoutez c'est quand même
lamentable on a fourni aux Argentins des
armes pour torturer leur peuple il y a
3-4 ans maintenant il est retourne
contre nous on veut les battre et en
plus on achète des armes à la France ou
des trucs tout ça ça me rend malade il
disait un peu et il est au chômage en
plus et c'est les gens qui étaient au
chômage sans travail qui disait une
certaine vérité les autres ils voulaient
en découdre
là il y avait deux images si vous voulez
elles étaient elles étaient et c'est les
deuxièmes c'est ça qu'il faut montrer
dans dans quatre jours vous saurez si
les commandos anglais tiennent ou
tiennent pas ça sera intéressant d'y
être aujourd'hui et que vos moyens ben
non parce que Jean-Luc Godard vous savez
très bien que les moyens ce sont ceux
que les militaires britanniques ou
argentins peuvent blesser à des
journalistes que c'est de faire leur
travail et vous vous doutez bien que les
envoyer spéciaux de la télé de toute
télévision sauf la télévision
britannique ne sont pas présents sur le
lieu des combats c'est la guerre
Jean-Luc Godard la moins filmée du monde
c'est mon métier et si vous souhaiteriez
vous moi personnellement moi je crois
que personnellement comme métier mais je
crois que j'ai eu ma dose de guerre
comme tout reporter qui commence et de
montrer la guerre en direct vous pensez
moi je pense qu'on puisse la monter en
direct Jean-Luc Jean et on y vient et on
y vient les jeux du cirque et la guerre
est faite pour passer à la télévision
donc dans trois jours vous en parlerez
plus comme le Niger
ça fait 7 semaines qu'on parle des
Malouines Jean-Luc Godard tous les jours
ou presque on en parle non mais disons
dans trois semaines mais dans trois
semaines quelques qui peut vous dire que
pouvez-vous dire sur ce qui se passera
dans le monde en trois semaines Jean-Luc
mais là pour l'instant ce que je peux
dire je peux pas rien vous dire sur les
mains oui parce que je ne sais pas
si si vous êtes exposé mais nous ne
savons pas non plus ce qui se passe mais
c'est peut-être déjà une information
pourquoi vous me dites pas Philippe vous
commencez pas votre journal en disant je
ne sais pas j'ai commencé mon journal
Jean-Luc en disant information
contradictoire et confuse l'Argentine
dit une chose Londres autre chose
information contradictoire vous n'avez
l'air de savoir que c'est un formation
contradictoire dites moi chef d'antenne
2 je ne sais pas ce qui se passe mais
d'abord je ne suis pas chef d'antenne
non première information
deuxièmement
ce n'est pas une bonne définition
speaker Jean-Luc Godard
ce qui s'est passé vous pouvez dire ça
je n'ai pas vu ce qui s'est passé au
Malouines ça vous convient ça vous
satisfait très bien merci Jean-Luc mais
restez avec nous parce que le dialogue
est intéressant
professeur là on fait un bon ordinateur
ça se passe pas trop mal pour l'instant
avec cependant un point noir au niveau
des jeunes voilà en effet une demi-heure
que l'émission est commencé et on a
toujours pas entendu une note de musique
résultat et bien une hémorragie
alarmante de notre clientèle des 15 24
ans
notamment au nord de la Loire lesquels
15 24 ans représente quand même je vous
le rappelle 47,5% de part de marché sur
le créneau des marchands de cartables et
des réparateurs de Solex alors je crois
qu'il faut réagir très rapidement j'ai
de la musique prendre de la musique
Michael Jackson serait-il atteint à son
tour par le virus Bruel il veut faire de
sa nouvelle chanson anime mondial pour
qu'il n'y ait plus jamais de guerre et
que tous les gens soient heureux pour
toujours voici hildaworld en français
soigner le monde numéro 2 au top 50
[Musique]
alors
on a vu beaucoup de choses
[Musique]
ça manque de comment on est pas très
concerné en fait
je pense ça touche pas les gens
il faut toucher les gens à mon avis
[Applaudissements]
que ça touche les gens faudrait que les
gens se sentent complètement entraînés
quoi
que ce soit large bien sûr
que ça soit que ça soit fort enfin que
ce soit bah oui si vous voulez faut
quand même temps c'est mais quand même
non plus
c'est les deux les deux à la fois c'est
pas simple c'est sûr mais bon c'est
parce que là on est un petit peu
merci merci beaucoup professeur oui je
crois que c'est très clair hein
j'entends ces observations je crois
qu'il y a très clairement de la part du
téléspectateur une demande très forte
dans le sens de la qualité alors c'est
prévu c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
allons diffuser maintenant un
documentaire culturel sur la ville de
Venise et ses musées seulement dans la
mesure où le téléspectateur n'a pas
encore le niveau intellectuel suffisant
pour regarder ce document dans son
intégralité nos chiffres et nos enquêtes
le monde nous allons en diffuser 29
secondes cette semaine et puis la
semaine prochaine par contre lorsque les
téléspectateurs seront habitués lorsque
leur niveau aura un petit peu augmenté
on pourra en diffuser 43 secondes et
puis ainsi de suite en augmentant de
semaine en semaine jusqu'à ce qu'il
puisse le voir en entier voilà
le grand canal fort Venise d'ouest en
est large et profonde cassure en forme
de S S comme Sérénissime et tout au long
de ce grand canal côte à côte s'appuyant
les uns sur les autres les palais
s'alignent dans une harmonie nullement
altérée par la variété des styles
je crois que j'enregistre la
satisfaction de nos amis Irène et
Jean-Pierre je crois que le service
public a rempli sa mission alors en
revanche en ce qui concerne les chiffres
ça ne va pas fort fort et je commence à
avoir une petite inquiétude pour le
chien notre petit zap me semble très
légèrement menacé je crois qu'il serait
temps si vous avez quelque chose de fort
si vous avez quelque chose qui puisse un
petit peu nous faire repartir c'est le
moment Thierry j'ai ce qu'il vous faut
professeur vous voulez un scoop ouais
j'ai un vrai scoop là
c'est ce qu'il faut pour faire monter
l'ardimat j'ai l'interview exclusive de
l'assassin de John Lennon my chop man ce
n'est pas Lennon que j'ai voulu tuer
dit-il mais une pochette de 10 en fait
il voulait être aussi célèbre que celui
qui avait déclaré être aussi célèbre que
le Christ Mike Chapman
[Musique]
j'ai entendu cette voix pas une voix
claire mais une voix imperceptible qui
me disait encore et encore vas-y fais-le
vas-y c'était à l'intérieur de moi
j'ai sorti le revolver de ma poche
j'étais dans tous mes états
j'ai levé le revolver
je l'ai serré très fort de ma main
gauche et j'ai tiré cinq coups réguliers
dans son dos
c'était la fin du film
de movie
j'étais aussi là pendant quelques
minutes et puis du coin de l'oeil
j'ai vu cette silhouette s'approchait de
la fenêtre de la voiture
c'était Yoko
elle a regardé je l'ai regardé j'étais
foudroyé par son regard
elle cherchait à comprendre à savoir
mais qui est ce monstre ignoble qui
vient de tuer John Lennon mon mari je
veux voir ce rat ce [ __ ]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai imploré 7 ans de me venir en aide
parce que je savais que tout seul je
n'arriverai pas à tuer un homme
alors j'ai suivi une sorte de rituel
pour devenir une créature de Satan
j'ai enlevé tous mes vêtements et j'ai
crié j'ai poussé des hurlements
je dois vous dire comment m'est venu
l'idée de tuer John Lennon au début
j'étais à la bibliothèque et je suis
tombé sur le livre d'Anthony facette
John Lennon one day Red Star
et j'ai appris dans ce livre qu'il
vivait dans un coin
ultra chic de Manhattan et sa meilleure
de moi
tout ce que je sais c'est que j'étais
complètement désespéré l'idée de toute
sensation
un super moyen face à cette grande
personnalité que je pensais bidon moi le
moins que rien je voulais abattre cette
personnalité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que j'ai cru qu'en le tuant je
deviendrai aussi célèbre que lui
je vous en prie Yoko essayez de
comprendre ce n'était pas un être humain
que j'ai voulu tuer c'est une image que
je voulais tuer la couverture d'un album
alors professeur
Thierry je constate que vous avez fait
un gros effort vous avez tiré avec ce
document exclusif une de vos meilleurs
cartouches et pourtant l'hémorragie
continue tous les clignotants sont dans
le rouge et là je dois vous dire que je
ne donne pas bien cher de l'avenir du
petit chien zap c'est pas croyable je ne
sais plus ce qu'on peut faire bah si ben
quoi super Joker
on peut m'envoyer super Joker s'il vous
plaît
dans toutes les émissions de télé super
Joker celui qui fait monter l'audience
ouais j'en ai fait ma profession
maintenant ça y est je suis profession
invité donc super Joker qui fait monter
les audimats et j'arrive à temps parce
que là c'est la dégringolade
j'ai marché normalement jusqu'ici je
pense à charger
j'en fais pas des tonnes
je reste peut-être
si vous pouvez faire quelque chose pour
nous parce que l'art du mat vous voulez
non je sais c'est pas c'est pas
valorisant pour l'émission
mais ça fait ses preuves sur d'autres
chaînes et je crois que l'histoire drôle
la blague à la con quoi le truc débile
alors bon ben j'espère que vous la
connaissez pas et si vous la connaissez
je compte sur vous le dites rien c'est
c'est c'est deux éléphants qui sont dans
la jungle qui qui sont là ils la
connaissent aussi
ok il rigole d'avance donc c'est super
Joker c'est ça et ces deux éléphants qui
sont dans la jungle et et et et il y en
a et elles vont près d'un lac et puis il
y en a une qui va puis qui se baigne
dans l'eau et elle est là et elle
s'arrose elle s'éclate et tout ça puis à
l'autre défendent qui reste près de la
berge comme ça et puis l'autre régime
était folle mais tu es folle mais viens
c'est rafraîchissant tu devrais te
baigner avec moi non tu as dit mais non
je peux pas j'ai mes ragnagna mais
[ __ ] mais fais comme moi mais un
mouton
pour rester un peu dans le service
public si vous voulez ça je suis moins
sûr hein
Monsieur et Madame Camille ont un fils
SIM SIM Camille
Monsieur et Madame Villard ont une fille
Hervée
non bon bah dans ces cas là je vais me
lancer les manches de faire un sketch au
boulot
j'ai essayé un truc sympa c'est les
vacances c'est une agence de voyage qui
m'a conseillé bien sur le catalogue il y
avait marqué
kumaki pas cher le billet d'abord bon
voyage sur une compagnie qui s'appelle
charters 45 heures de vol
Bruxelles Bruxelles Londres Londres
Barcelone Barcelone Los Angeles Los
Angeles Grenoble Grenoble kumak et quand
tu arrives là-bas la première chose que
tu fais tu dors forcément faut que tu
récupères j'ai dormi 77 heures je me
suis réveillé un mercredi à minuit
j'avais une autre patate d'enfer
seulement à minuit là-bas il y a rien à
faire tout est fermé non parce qu'on est
12 heures de décalage horaire mais point
de vue niveau de vie il y a trois
siècles de décalage horaire pendant une
semaine je me suis réveillé à minuit les
nuits sont belles longue mais belle mais
longue et puis j'étais malade j'ai perdu
12 kilos non mais c'est de ma faute j'ai
fait une connerie j'ai bu un verre d'eau
non mais c'est de ma faute la connerie
quoi là-bas c'est soda kinine soda
kinine en boîte whisky killing me
quinine il faut pas s'amuser à boire
l'alcool local il le boivent toi tu le
mets dans ta mobylette tu montes à 160
il a le goût du monde parce qu'il
rajoute du canard WC
le tel bien oui attention la photo de
l'hôtel sur le prospectus c'est le
projet la plage elle existe au nord de
l'hôtel à 50 km de brousse de toute
façon ça sert à rien de content de
kilomètres faut compter en heures un
kilomètre de brousse ça fait une heure
pour aller à la plage tu parles avec
mais quand tu arrives là-bas bien
raison
il y a 40 degrés l'ombre là-bas il y a
pas d'ombre
là-bas le soleil c'est pas ton ami
là-bas c'est crème solaire indice de
protection 18-20 XL XXL
t-shirt manches longues en coton parce
que la ballon quand ça vous a brûle
et puis la mer bleue chaude et pas de
requin trop dangereux de ne pas les
requins
du coup merde dangereuse soleil agressif
alcool nocif tu visites
forcément kumak tu visites pas par
plaisir
vraie nature celle d'avant hostile
là-bas oublie les Rangers non parce que
scorpion ça dort dans les Rangers
c'est pas du matin le Scorpion de toute
façon moi les Rangers je pourrais plus
les mettre après la première piqûre je
chaussais du 82
je m'étais plus des Adidas pas les
chaussures les sacs de sport
je vais essayer de vous le faire
les moustiques j'avais amené de la
citronnelle erreur point
des vrais moustiques gros comme des
libellule à côté les Scorpions c'est
peace and love
tu dis oui une fois
par contre le retour tout seul dans
l'avion mais le luxe tout le monde au
petit soin pour toi ah je voyais plus
qu'avec Europe assistance voilà
énorme succès du côté des agriculteurs
les courbes sont en flèche vers le haut
un petit peu moins bien chez les
détaillants en pâté mais bon résultat
quand même normal la Nouvelle-Calédonie
l'ardimat est bon mieux que ça bon
parfait je vous dois à combien super
Joker 40 secondes à 40 secondes
il y en a qui sont moins chers
émission
faites vos 40 secondes super Joker merci
vous me laissez moi je vous en prie
le 19 janvier je passe à Reims voilà
donc venez me voir nombreux il y a mon
spectacle il passe à Reims le 19 janvier
après j'attaque Longjumeau le 22 je
serai Val-de-Reuil Val-de-Reuil 23
janvier le 25 janvier je suis dans la
région de Bordeaux je suis même à
Bordeaux pour dire pour être plus précis
je suis à Bordeaux n'oubliez pas que sur
les écrans de cinéma en ce moment il y a
un film formidable qui est le film de
Collins c'est une femme formidable que
j'aime beaucoup qui est une grande
réalisatrice qui s'appelle la crise avec
de grands comédiens comme Vincent Lindon
Zabou Maria Pacôme qui fait un numéro
exceptionnel le film marche je vous
entends taper là sur les
deux
40 secondes
avant de partir quand même pour la suite
de l'émission à ce prix là non politique
attaquer la politique
faut attaquer la politique d'accord
c'est nos plus gros concurrents la
police
ils sont d'ailleurs très drôle souvent
merci merci
à un retour en force dans la vie des
Français le débat est à nouveau
passionnant hier Raymond Barre chez
Bernard Pivot aujourd'hui Bernard Tapie
cherdimat voici la profession de foi du
Premier ministre de la Ville claire
précis 30 secondes utile rien à jeter
[Musique]
mais qu'est-ce qui vous fait marcher moi
ça marche à la longueur
plus 40% de durée
voilà c'était
notre contribution débat politique en
France à 3 mois des législatives alors
tu me cites
ça nous touche en même temps que
voudriez voir quoi maintenant cette
heure-là
normalement on va plutôt au lit là
maintenant
avec un bon bouquin quoi si vous voulez
au coin du feu voilà un bon feu de bois
on a tout ce qu'il faut
ben voilà je crois que tout le monde
peut se le procurer ce feu de bois c'est
une cassette ma vidéo qui s'appelle le
feu de cheminée sans la corvée de bois
et il y a aussi l'aquarium pour avoir
chez vous un aquarium voilà ça vous ça
vous va enfin c'est divertissant on a le
vrai quand même hein
je crois que ça permet aux gens de
redécouvrir les plaisirs de la lecture
je crois que là encore le service public
a bien rempli sa mission je crois que
j'ai quelque chose pour vous maintenant
professeur Rollin s'il vous plaît je
crois que j'ai du sensationnel qui va
faire remonter leur dit maths
il est en néo il est temps après la
politique nous allons maintenant aborder
les problèmes religieux mais avant de
lancer ce sujet je voudrais vous faire
part des doutes de la rédaction
d'ardimat quant à son authenticité on
pense qu'il est bidonné on se demande si
c'est de l'info ou si c'est de l'interse
j'ai entendu la patron ah non mais
c'était un
quartier
Philippe c'était comme ça c'est une
formule tout le monde emploie cette
formule maintenant c'était que nous ça
double jeu c'est fini double jeu je peux
faire autre chose un tour de magie ah
non tu es vachement bien
un paquet de clopes
je t'appellerai s'il y a quelque chose
il faut sortir
[Applaudissements]
les sœurs de la Sainte Famille oeuvres
dans le quartier le plus malfamé de
Philadelphie leur orphelinat est
constamment menacé de vol ou devant
d'Alice les cas d'agression d'enfants
sont fréquents et deux non ne furent
même violet
[Musique]
refusant de renoncer après 80 ans
d'apostola les sœurs ont découvert dans
l'Ancien Testament une solution à leurs
problèmes
œil pour œil dent pour dent
[Musique]
comme les moines orientaux du vieux
monastère de Shaolin ses sœurs modernes
se sont convertis aux arts martiaux
[Musique]
pour l'instant leur technique est
purement défensive mais si une vie est
en jeu si la chasse tetée d'une femme
était menacée ces bonnes soeurs auraient
recours à des prises plus énergiques
[Musique]
je suis obligé de vous redire ce que
j'ai dit le mois dernier dans ma
conférence à Madrid tout ça c'est quand
même jamais que des images préfabriquées
c'est de la conserve vous comprenez la
vraie vie n'est pas là les remplacerai
jamais le vrai spectacle le vrai
spectacle c'est le moment où je sais pas
c'est le moment où c'est un ours qui
marche avec des pigeons sur la tête vous
comprenez c'est le moment où tout d'un
coup ça décolle c'est une autre
dimension c'est ça que les gens
demandent finalement on a un ours est-ce
qu'on peut avoir un ours avec des
pigeons sur la tête
rentrer l'ours
[Musique]
avec un pigeon sur la tête
bonsoir alors professeur
à votre invité c'est pour moi c'est ma
tournée est-ce qu'on pourrait avoir un
petit peu de champagne notre ami ours
[Musique]
merci
allez à la Sainte Russie MacDo
[Musique]
merci beaucoup merci Maga on va
professeur je crois que c'est
[Musique]
faut pas déconner quand même une
demi-heure de merde écoute c'est simple
mais on s'en va mais tais-toi
on n'est pas les moutons regarde-moi ça
ça applaudit
c'est n'importe quoi je me casse moi
pour faire ça bah non tu m'excuseras non
c'est vrai c'est truqué alors vraiment
c'est son chien avec sa télé c'est nul
laisse tomber merci
aller chez Sabatier chez lui il y a des
chiffres
alors là ça va ça va ça va ça va non
mais c'est toi qui a voulu venir là
ah c'est nul hein
[Musique]
ce document
voilà
micro vous avez là entre autres beauté
un très joli chien est-ce qu'on peut lui
dire bonjour
vous croyez qu'il le fera je peux me
prêter je peux me pencher pour voir le
chien
attention c'est moi qui lui fait peur
je suis très content oui
vous faites fausse route notre cible qui
est composé essentiellement de jeunes
peu instruits ne connaît pas cette Jane
Mansfield notre cible
mais c'est parler ceux qui connaissent
quelque chose cette infernal ça à la fin
notre cible Thierry les chiffres le
montrent elle attend qu'on lui parle de
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui elle veut
qu'on lui parle de ce dont tout le monde
parle c'est ça qu'elle attend notre
cible ah bon évidemment Dracula Dracula
alors le dernier Dracula est sorti
mercredi comme à chaque lancement d'un
gros film américain les médias vous en
ont rebattu les oreilles jour et nuit je
n'en dirai pas plus
[Musique]
mais pas celui-là mais d'où ça sort ça
j'ai jamais demandé ça j'ai demandé le
Dracula de Coppola ah mais je le crois
pas ça mais
je suis là mais c'est encore pas
celui-là
ça fait le troisième que vous mettez
c'est toujours pas le bon
c'est ici que se déroula l'effroyable et
révoltants d'histoires du prince Dracula
et de la femme qui les met
j'ai traversé des océans d'éternité pour
vous trouver
ez
[Musique]
il a écouté sombre sinistre qui me dit
résistible
jamais je n'ai rencontré un homme aussi
et pris de la vie
il ne ressemble à nul autre
[Musique]
battons-le affrontons-le
se métamorphose
à la fois jeune et vieux
il peut devenir brut vapeur
et disparaître à volonté
le pouvoir de son désir maléfique et
sans limite
tu voudras que vous alliez faire lui il
faudra que vous l'aimiez
c'est son allié délibéré sa fidèle
fanatique c'est la continuité du démon
Dre joignez moi dans la vie éternelle
votre salut naîtra de sa destruction
vous être ce que vous êtes je veux voir
ce que vous voyez je voulais mettre vous
aimez alors délivrez moi de ce manque
alors l'émission touche à sa fin il est
temps de faire un petit bilan alors ça
vous a plu
globalement
il y a des choses bien il y a vraiment
des pibons c'est il y a du bon il y a du
moins bon aussi il y a des moments
peut-être qu'il y a des moments où il y
aura peut-être il y a des baisses quoi
de temps en temps
confirmer la deuxième
[Musique]
peut-être que ça va comme ça prendre son
élan ça peut intéresser ça peut marcher
enfin mais dites-moi dans mais dites-moi
dites-moi franchement
avant le samedi soir on regardait
si vous voulez c'est si
ça vous plaisait
c'est peut-être la découverte
des expéditions scientifiques françaises
américaines et turcs se sont succédé à
couscoï
aucune n'a réussi à percer le mystère
des siffleurs ni le lien qui pourrait
exister avec les trois autres régions du
monde où l'on utilise aussi la langue
sifflée les Turcs eux sont sûrs que la
langue d'oiseau a été inventée chez eux
[Musique]
dans la rivière
[Rires]
personne ne sait quand et pourquoi on a
commencé à siffler dans cette vallée
c'est ainsi la vie à couzkoï commence et
finit par des sifflements
[Musique]
c'est notre deuxième langue maternelle
distille les enfants la connaissent
avant de savoir parler
on peut tous dire en sifflant tout ce
qui fait la vie quotidienne on se
dispute on s'insulte en sifflant
les sifflements portent plus loin que la
voix jusqu'à 2 km et demi et couvre le
tumulte de la rivière c'est ainsi que
leur annonce de maison en maison les
naissances ou les morts
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu